what I want to attempt to do in this
video is figure out what the sine of 7
PI over 12 is without using a calculator
and so let's just visualize 7 PI over 12
on the unit circle so one side of the
angle is going along the positive x-axis
and then let's see if we go straight up
that's PI over 2 which is the same thing
as 6 PI over 12 so then we essentially
just have another PI over 12 to get
right over there this is the angle that
we're talking about that is 7 PI over 12
radians and the sign of it by the unit
circle definition of sine it comes it's
the y coordinate of where this ray
intersects the unit circle so is the
unit circle has radius one where it
intersects the unit the y coordinate is
the sine so another way to think about
it it's the length it's the length of
this line right over here and I
encourage you to pause the video right
now and try to think about it on your
own see if you can use your powers of
trigonometry to figure out what sine of
7 PI over 12 is or essentially the
length of this magenta line so I'm
assuming you've given a go at it and if
you're like me your first temptation
might have been just to focus on this
triangle right over here that I kind of
drew for you so the triangle looks like
this it looks like this where that's
what you're trying to figure out this
length right over here set sine of 7 PI
over 12 we know the length of the we
know the length of the hypotenuse is 1
it's a radius of the unit circle it's a
right triangle right over there and we
also know this angle right over here
which is this angle right over here this
gets a 6 PI over 12 then we have another
PI over 12 so we know that that is PI
over 12 not PI over 16 we know that this
angle right over here is PI over 12 and
so given this information we can figure
out this this or we can at least relate
this side to these other sides using a
trig function relative to this angle
this is the adjacent side and so the
cosine of PI over 12 is going to be this
magenta side over 1 or you could just
say it's equal to this magenta side so
you could say this is cosine
of pi over 12 so we just figured out
that sine of 7 PI over 12 is the same
thing as cosine of PI over 12 but that
still doesn't help me I don't know
offhand what the cosine of PI over 12
radians is without using a calculator so
let's instead of thinking about it this
way let's see if we can compose this
angle or if we can decompose it into
some angles for which we do know the
sine and cosine and what angles are
those well those are the angles and
special right triangles so for example
we are very familiar with 30 60 90
triangles 30 60 90 triangles look
something like this this is my best
attempt at hand drawing it if they have
so instead of writing the 30-degree side
I'll write since we're thinking in
radians I'll write that as PI over 6
radians the 60-degree side I'm going to
write that as PI over 3 radians and of
course this is the right angle and if
the hypotenuse here is 1 then the side
opposite the 30-degree side of the PI
over 6 radians side is going to be 1/2
the hypotenuse which in this case is 1/2
and then the other side that's opposite
the 60-degree side or the PI over 3
radians side is going to be square root
of 3 times the shorter side so it's
going to be square root of 3 over 2 and
so we've used these types of triangles
in the past to figure out the sine or
cosine of 30 or 60 or in this case PI
over 6 or PI over 3 so this we know
about PI over 6 and PI over 3 we also
know about 45-45-90 triangles we know
that they're isosceles right triangles
they look like this my best attempt at
drawing it that one actually doesn't
look that isosceles so let me let me
make it let me make it a little bit more
so I don't know that looks closer to
being ice and isosceles right triangle
and we know if the length of the
hypotenuse is 1 and this comes straight
out of Pythagorean theorem then the
length of each of the other two sides
are going to be square root of 2 over 2
times the hypotenuse which is this case
is the square root of 2 over 2 instead
of describing these as 45-degree angles
we know that's the same thing as PI over
4 PI over 4 radians and so if you give
me PI over 6 PI over 3 PI over 4 I can
use these triangles either using the
classic definition sohcahtoa definitions
or I could stick them on the unit circle
here to use the unit circle definition
of trig functions to figure out what the
sine cosine or tangent of these angles
are so can I decompose 7 PI over 12 into
some combination of pi over 6 is PI over
3 s or PI over 4 s well to think about
that let me rewrite PI over 6 PI over 3
and PI over 4 with the denominator over
12 so let me write that so PI over 6 is
equal to 2 PI over 12 PI over 3 is equal
to 4 PI over 12 and PI over 4 is equal
to 3 PI over 12 so let's see 2 plus 4 is
not 7 2 plus 3 is not 7 but 4 plus 3 is
7 so I could use this and this 4 PI over
12 plus 3 PI over 12 is 7 PI over 12 so
I could rewrite this this is the same
thing as sine of 3 PI over 12 3 PI over
12 plus 4 PI plus 4 PI over 12 which of
course is the same thing sine of PI over
4 I'll do this in another color sine of
PI over 4 plus plus let me do this plus
PI over 3 plus PI over 3 and now we can
use our angle addition formula for sine
in order to write this as the sum of
products of cosines and sines of these
angles so let's actually do that so this
right over here is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to the sine
the sine of PI over 4 times the cosine
of PI over 3 times the cosine of PI over
3 plus the other way around
cosine of PI over 4 cosine of PI over 4
times the sine of PI over 3 sine of PI
over 3 so now we just have to figure out
these things and I've already set up the
triangles to do it
what is sine of PI over 4 sine of PI
over 4 well let's let's think about this
is PI over 4 right over here sine is
opposite over hypotenuse well it's just
going to be square root of 2 over 2 so
this is square root of 2 over 2 square
root of 2 over 2 what is cosine of PI
over 3 well this is a PI over 3 radians
over here cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so this is going to be its
adjacent over hypotenuse so this is
going to be one half what is cosine of
PI over 4 we'll go back to PI over 4 so
it's adjacent over hypotenuse it's
square root of 2 over 2
it is also square root of 2 over 2
square root of 2 over 2 and what's sine
of PI over 3 well sine sine is opposite
over hypotenuse so it's square root of 3
over 2 over 1 square root of 3 over 2
divided by 1 which is square root of 3
over 2 and so now we just have to
simplify all of this business so this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to the sum of this or the product
I should say is just square root of 2
over 4 and then plus plus the product of
these let's see we could rewrite that is
we could write that as square root of 6
over 4 square root of 6 over 4 or we
could just rewrite this whole thing as
and we deserve our we deserve a little
bit of a we deserve a little bit of a
drumroll at this point this is
equivalent to let me scroll over to the
right a little bit this is equivalent to
square root of 2 plus square root of 6
plus square root of 6 all of that all of
that over 4 that's what sine of 7 PI
over 12 is or cosine of PI over 12 what
that is equal to